à quelques jours de la rentrée voici un
premier problème de maths le
gouvernement a annoncé que le port du
masque sera obligatoire à l'intérieur
des salles de classe pour les plus de 11
ans deux masques à 95 centimes par jour
cinq jours par semaine
alors qui doit payer l'état tout à fait
nous les gens voilà ils ont pas
peut-être pas les moyens de les acheter
des masques
je comprends pas pourquoi les masques on
devrait les payer quoi un gros budget si
l'épidémie dur oui c'est bien ça le
problème quoi puisqu'on n'a pas de
provision à terme la fin d'épidémie donc
service culture et 8 normalement ça
devrait être le gouvernement
je regrette c'est moi je suis pas
d'accord là dessus ça a eu payé
c'est pas nouveau mais le principe de
gratuité n'a pas été retenue par le
gouvernement sauf pour les familles les
plus précaires pour le premier ministre
jean reste est le masque n'est pas une
fourniture scolaire
alors ils annoncent l'état ne prendra
pas en charge cette dépense
le conseil départemental de saône et
loire a résolu problème il va équiper
les 61 collèges du département avec la
collaboration de dim a autant à partir
du moment où l'état ne fournit pas c'est
à dire l'éducation nationale ne fournit
pas les masques aux collégiens et bien
lundi j'ai pris la décision avec mes
collègues immédiatement de fournir les
masques à tous les collégiens de saône
et loire
cent trente mille masques ont été
commandés mais andré accary rassure ça
ne coûtera pas un centime aux parents je
me suis engagé au printemps à ce que le
département face des stocks de masques
et on ne se retrouve pas dans cette
situation ubuesque du printemps est donc
tout simplement je tiens mon engagement
on doit offrir le maximum de sécurité à
l'ensemble des élèves département la
démarche a convaincu d'autres présidents
de départements comme l'allier où l'un
on est prêt pour la rentrée affirme jean
castex la saône et loire
aussi les vingt cinq mille collégiens du
département feront leur rentrée ce mardi
avec le sourire mais bien masqué